[Music]
there's a hot social media app in town
called Twitter oh yeah on it man I've
never heard of it I love it
you have a checkmark probably a lot I
have a check do you follow a lot of
people you follow anyone that we know
you don't follow 200 people that's
awesome huh 200 under fire Twitter no no
no they're actually trying to fix some
things because the youths have been
using it but then the old started giving
on it okay yeah and when a lot of people
start getting on it there is a spreading
of misinformation that can happen
because people will see an article and
then they will share that article
without reading the article so they just
read the headlines and then they retweet
it right and then no one ever reads the
article they just read the headline
that's which which is hard because then
once they find out that the headline was
misleading
no one goes and corrects the headline so
Twitter is trying to do a new thing
where if you try to share an article
without reading it it will recognize
that you didn't read the article and
with a prompt that says are sharing an
article can spark conversation so you
may want to read it before you tweet it
interesting it's also they know that you
didn't read it you have a questionnaire
a questionnaire like a test or like you
have to clear the response like a
reading comprehension test with like
everything especially with the news
right now people are just be posting to
the show like their support yeah but
they don't know what their post yeah
yeah and also so many like websites and
and and companies they'll come up with
just a click Beatty title Idol even
though like it the article will have say
it will say something completely
different but they just want the
retweets and all that you know but but
it's always the bottom of the article
they take it all back you know really
actually found is it's not really true
right it's always just you know trying
to get people to click yeah like aliens
are breaking houses and
stealing things or are they it's almost
like there's a corporatist media
environment that exists to produce
clicks an outrage that people click on
things to sell ads it sounds impossible
impossible that's a conspiracy probably
I'm just nuts so they're testing us on
Android to see if the Android users like
it why because they're smarter they're
dumber the ones spreading all the false
information Android users yeah they're
more likely to be woke bro you have no
real world though not [ __ ] was like
real work they actually know what's
going is they're like we don't care
about the [ __ ] blue bubbles we just
care that this phone works better yeah I
was just trying to because no one has an
Android in this room right now they
don't care about the blue balls those
green bubble blue bubble is so you when
you're staring at your phone waiting for
the text you can see them text the old
dots yeah Seletar so your anxiety goes
up and it feels better yep my anxiety
only goes up and I see it the dots they
just disappear when they leave you on
red yeah red that's mean bro do you have
you have your ever seats on no I mean
you I do I do it says a lot about a
president and they don't have them when
they don't have it on why they're hiding
some [ __ ] I just don't like to only bill
the note I don't want people to think of
personally I like to save all my
responses for the end of the day but
I'll check him throughout the day I just
don't want my mom to know I'm ignoring
her yeah that's really it I wish you
couldn't like choose to say red yeah you
can no no like per person no I read it
yeah I just text back red at this time
yeah I am in confirmation I'm in receipt
of your text yeah like like the way your
mom who doesn't get that where it says
like like Nicki like this image oh yeah
so my mom's an android user and we're in
a group convo and everyone else has an
iPhone except for her so when that
happens we when you normally like an
image it just shows a heart but if
there's an Android person in there it
types the whole thing out so-and-so
liked this text message
and so my mom didn't know why everyone
kept typing Robyn liked this message so
she wrote haha lol Darcy laughs she's
like everyone's talking to me to it dude
it's wild it's wild help yes she had to
but you could tell because she put haha
lol first and then laughs that's cute it
was really cute Nikki's dad so he helped
me with my taxes couple years ago talk
to those and bunch of people think that
he paid my taxes it's not what happened
he [ __ ] helped me know figure it out
because you see PA but maybe he did help
a little bit so when he sent me the game
plan I set my [ __ ] to him and he said
which is weird and haunting for me even
to this day he said received that's it
yeah he does that to me sue there's no
like personal connection of this he's
like received period my dad has a
business hat and then he has his like
normal hat and like when he's in
business mode he just he's being
efficient I get it but I'm like mad I
feel the same would you got to be like a
received smiley face received
exclamation point he's not like that
give me the [ __ ] emoji were the guys
like no he's working that's all the
types of girls when they say like a nude
or no Nadine liked this image that might
turn them on even more with like can't
yeah I'm serious
I'm a cinnamon eggy yeah it's like he's
a texting back with like white gloves on
like received yeah yeah Nadeem smacked
the phone oh my dad he puts okay period
in a text oh he it [ __ ] me spell out
okay - no no he okay okay I hate when
people text yo or a hey and they don't
text anything after so you just high
anxiety because now you got type
something yo what's up and then they
tell you what they're gonna take you
could have just text view what their
eyes and hear when they do that when you
are already open up the conversation so
if I'm like hey Nadine and you're right
yo that's cool with me but if I'm like
hey Nadine how's rollercoaster ride
yesterday I know they're looking forward
to it
yo
then I'm like there you just ignored
everything I just asked look I didn't
you just start the conversation I
started the conversation you started it
because you having to learn on your
phone because to start a conversation
with him that's true I scheduled it was
a long I just hate the people that um
text like it's [ __ ] like aim so it's
like yo so it's like so his thing I was
wondering if maybe then you put the
differently I'm a nice pen and I like ya
is a voice message leaver
yeah dude I mean I just started doing
that like a voice message through text
or oh yeah and I need to hold it to you
yeah I actually like that huh yeah like
it too
I used to hate it when Dietrich's would
always even without it he always does it
and I used to hate it I thought it was
so weird until one day I was just like
driving and I was like yeah you know I
can't I was like alright so here's the
thing man and I started doing I was like
this is really convenient he also has
really good energy so what do you
actually listen to it well you guys
should try texting machine Dawson cuz it
tell you what a you text a lot with that
guy you know you drop this oh I thought
that's what we were doing oh I see yeah
I know I text with Shane does well
features has actually been on this show
yeah lame-o I'll give you that one else
poke you mean yes Philip DeFranco and
like
yeah or you like I used to watch the one
else you need to know what pokey man's
is we already did this he doesn't know
anything
what the [ __ ] we're talking about
anymore we're talking about Twitter
commenting Oh Vegas water no he thought
our dish was a Zelda [ __ ] enemy it's a
pokey man
you know what happened on Instagram now
- I think because like the whole Trump
thing and with Twitter short enough you
guys did I think he was explaining stuff
that they said was like misinformation
so they what they do is before you can
even read the tweet or before you can
even see the Instagram post you have to
confirm that this has been fly for
misinformation and you have to read why
they say that yeah dumb though because
the sources that they cited are sources
that have people who are like you know
[ __ ] trompetol and [ __ ] so it's like
that's not fair and you have to be fair
yeah be fair that's like like I'm not
I'm fan of Trump but no that's just
being fair it's a freedom of speech and
stuff like that you have to get your
information somewhere
everyone can spread misinformation right
but then that's a good way to combat
that's not fighting their freedom of
speech you know it's also just being
like here you never gonna be able to
count though did you hear about that
account that just tweeted anything that
Trump tweeted they would just tweet the
same thing to see how long it took for
them to get banned so [ __ ] funny yeah
they also try to launch this new
initiative a few weeks ago or last month
that limits like some people were able
to limit who could reply to their tweets
mmm on Android iOS and the company's web
app yeah you can make it so that only
the people that like follow yeah yeah
can reply to your [ __ ] if you don't just
do and you don't want to deal with other
people's like randoms opinions about
your tweet you know yeah you can
restrict to people they follow or people
they mention yeah I don't know cuz I
feel like if I won't post on social
media and then when I have a big open
I'm gonna let people talk right cuz my
friends also stupid and don't know what
the [ __ ] they're talking about sometimes
I don't so it's like I'd rather who does
nothing to see I'm not gonna name sup
I'm not oh well I know quite a few
people who know what they're talking
about if you want to do if you really
don't where you want to do it goes to
make the gosh